retour en france avec la suite et la fin
aujourd'hui de l'examen du projet de loi
contre les séparatismes à l'assemblée
nationale le vote solennel du texte
confortant les principes de la
république aura lieu mardi et jeudi
après un débat de près de 15 jours au
sein de l'hémicycle au total 2500 à 50
amendements la séance de ce matin au
palais bourbon intervient au lendemain
d'un débat sur france 2 entre marine le
pen et gérald darmanin
on retrouve tout de suite david khalifa
en direct du palais bourbon
david première séance ce matin en ce
moment même la science a commencé à 9h à
quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre pour
la suite et la fin des débats
une dizaine de nouveaux amendements
intègre y étudient ce matin au sein de
l'hémicycle je rappelle que ce projet de
loi comporte près de 70 l article qui
est ont provoqué de vifs débats au sein
de l'hémicycle mais également à travers
les médias dernier exemple en date vous
l'avez dit hier soir sur france 2 entre
gérald darmanin et marine le pen la
présidente du rassemblement national n'a
pas hésité à tacler le ministre de
l'intérieur sur les nombreux manquements
que comporte ce texte de loi écoutez je
suis déçu je m'attendais à une grande
loi de combat et nous avons à faire un
texte de police administrative vous vous
êtes attaqués à toutes les religions
alors que ce n'est pas un problème
religieux l'islamisme c'est un problème
d'idéologie l'islamisme radical dans le
viseur de marine le pen gérald darmanin
sca défendu en affirmant que la france
ne voulait pas faire de différence entre
les cultes les dispositions que nous
mettons dans ce texte vise à renforcer
la loi de 1905 qui est une grande loi de
liberté
le principal point d'achoppement de ce
projet de loi c'est à l'article 21
encore ce matin qui se porte sur la
restriction d'instruction en famille qui
concernerait quelque soixante deux mille
élèves en france visés par 384 et un
rendement record sur l'ensemble du texte
est une simple déclaration ne suffira
plus pour pouvoir enseigner à domicile
il faudra un désormais une autorisation
le gouvernement a tenté de désamorcer
les critiques de tous bords en proposant
une période de transition jusqu'en 2024
mais l'opposition dénonce une agression
à l'égard des familles elle suit donc
aujourd'hui ait des débats concernant
cet article 21 merci
david khalifa pour toutes les précisions
en direct donc de l'assemblée nationale
à paris